sunrise in kiev once again the sound of
gunfire in the distance as russian
forces come ever closer to ukraine's
capital
southwest of the city plumes of smoke
rise above an oil depot in vasselkeev
ukrainian forces said the fire began
after a russian airstrike
some western intelligence officials say
moscow's invasion is slower than
expected but the pace of russia's true
movement means little to people in
places like the southern city of volnova
look we were sitting in basements and
they were walking around everywhere
shooting we couldn't leave the basement
for over a day then i walked up to a
soldier and i said boys my mum is
bedridden up there she's a grandma and i
can't go up there the guys wanted to
help me bring her down into the basement
but when we went up there she had
already died it was already too late
in her kiev emergency workers search for
survivors in what's left of an apartment
block the eastern city has been shelled
for days by russian forces as has
chernahiv in the north of ukraine
reminders the past are everywhere in
this city but the present is
relentlessly bleak
the enemy is continuing air and rocket
shelling of the city of cherny heave
the peaceful population is dying and
there are many injured the enemy is
hitting civilian infrastructure western
ukraine has been spared the worst of the
conflict for now but things could be
changing in lutsk a russian missile
attack destroyed an airfield on the
city's outskirts
four soldiers were killed in the attack
on the airfield the funerals of two of
them have just taken place in this
church in the center of the city the
mayor of lutsk says the people here
though won't be intimidated by russian
forces
people just a little scared
but
we have no totally panic in our city we
we don't see
people live in our city we don't see
refugees live in our city and we
are still
we are still
believe
that ukraine
will win
110 kilometers from the border with
russia's ally belarus
some ukrainian officials say belarusian
troops could join the war others say
that's unlikely
if they want to come here let them come
but we will destroy them
and send them back in body bags
i hope belarus would reconsider their
position there's enough war it's a
massacre
the shelter in the city is now home for
vyaches slav and his family he says they
fled more than a week of unbearable
russian shelling his children cried
every day
ludsk is close to belarus but it's also
not far from the polish border
vyacheslav says they could go to germany
but for now he just feels lost
they took everything from me
i had a comfortable house the kids all
had their own room
now where will i go
and for what i'll have to start from
scratch
i'm not 20 anymore i'm 41.
for people caught up in this war there
are painful decisions often there are no
choices parents across ukraine are
struggling trapped in a terrible
situation they didn't create holding
their children's futures in their hands
natasha butler al jazeera lutzc
northwest ukraine